البستنة مفيدة لجسمك وعقلك ،
إنها تمرين رائع وهذا بالإضافة
إلى حقيقة أننا في الخارج في الشمس
مما يحفز فيتامين (د) يوفر
وقاية ممتازة من هشاشة العظام ، ولكن إذا
لم تكن حريصًا ، فإن البستنة يمكن أن
تؤثر سلبًا على جسمك لهذا السبب  من
المهم الانتباه إلى الطريقة
التي تعمل بها في الفناء ، تقول الدكتورة ديبرا
بنزل ، جراح الأعصاب في
معدات كليفلاند كلينك ، إنه أمر أساسي تمامًا إذا
كنت تحاول حفر شيء ما
والمجرفة الخاصة بك أو الأشياء بأسمائها ليست حادة
وهذا سيضع الكثير  المزيد من الضغط على
جسدك ، توصي benzel بمقعد الركوع
أو المقعد أثناء إزالة الأعشاب الضارة أو الزراعة لفترات طويلة ،
خاصة إذا كنت أكبر سنًا ،
كلما اقتربت منك نباتاتك ومعداتك ،
كلما قل الضغط على جسمك ،
كما تقول إنها ترفع ساقيك وليس
ظهرك و  استخدم عربة يدوية للمساعدة في
حمل الأحمال الثقيلة ، وتقول إن الانحناء
هو أسوأ شيء يمكنك القيام به أثناء
البستنة إذا كنت ستفعل ذلك ،
فعليك التأكد من قيامك
بتصويب جسمك.  بشكل منتظم للغاية
لأن الاحتفاظ بها في هذا الوضع المرن
لفترة طويلة أمر سيء حقًا بالنسبة
لك وتذكر أن تمدد قبل
ذلك وبعده له فائدة هائلة في تخفيف
هذا الانزعاج الذي يشعر به الكثير منا
بعد أن وضعنا ظهورنا في مواضع من
أجل  وقتًا طويلاً جدًا ، خذ أخيرًا
فترات راحة متكررة ولا تحاول أن تزرع
فناءك بالكامل مرة واحدة لدقيقة صحية ،
فأنا ماندي غايثر